- Hi. Welcome everyone.
My name is Priya Natarajan.
I'm an astrophysicist and
I'm the current director
of the Franke Program in Science
and the Humanities at Yale,
our flagship interdisciplinary program.
It's an absolute pleasure and
privilege to invite you all
to the opening event of the Franke program
in science and the humanities
for this academic year.
I would first like to start by thanking
our generous benefactors,
Richard and Barbara Franke.
Thanks, Barbara, for coming today.
Lovely to see you, for
their staunch support.
(audience applauds)
Of interdisciplinary scholarship
and engagement at Yale.
Thanks to their generous gift,
we are able to bridge the
so-called two cultures divide
and enable groundbreaking
exchange of ideas
and projects that span traditional
disciplinary boundaries.
And here is the customary required notice
because we are recording this event
that I'm obliged to read out.
Yale University is photographing
and videotaping this event.
There is a possibility
that you may be included
in these visuals by being
present during these activities.
You consent to the use of your appearance,
likeness and voice by Yale University
for standard, non-profit,
educational news-related
promotional and/or editorial purposes.
Okay, with that out of the
way, onto today's event.
We've been hearing a lot
about artificial intelligence
and the power and perils of the
rapid advances in the field.
One of the frontier and
open questions in the field
is whether we can build
computer systems, platforms,
maybe even a robot that can empathize
and connect like we humans do.
This still remains a challenge.
Meanwhile, we are also finally
paying a lot more attention
to animal intelligence and
communicating with them.
The wonderful recent film,
"My Octopus Teacher",
demonstrates that there is an
entire unexplored living world
out there under the sea.
Creatures from whom we have
much to learn and understand,
both about ourselves and
our wonderful planet.
I'm utterly delighted that Pippa Ehrlich,
the co-writer, director and
editor of "My Octopus Teacher",
is here with us today.
Welcome, Pippa.
It's great to have you here at Yale.
Thank you for coming.
(audience applauds)
Also, as per usual, we'll be gathering
for a dinner reception
with excellent food,
if I may say so myself,
upstairs in the Fellows Hall
immediately after this event.
So please do stay on.
So we're gonna start with
the screening of the film.
I'll tell you a little
bit more about the film
and following that, we'll
have a brief Q and A
with an opportunity for
all of you to engage
and ask Pippa some questions.
The Academy Award-winning film,
"My Octopus Teacher" follows the story
of the years Craig Foster
spent with a wild octopus.
Mr. Foster, suffering
from a loss of purpose,
begins a daily diving regimen
in the freezing kelp forest
at the tip of Africa in
order to re-energize himself.
What he discovers below
the water's surface
is a totally alien motivation in the form
of an unusually curious octopus.
This beautiful record of
an animal's entire life,
something seldom achieved in
the wild, let alone underwater,
was shot over an entire
year and explores the habits
and personality of a
strange undulating creature
that most of us, well not all
of us, have only ever eaten.
Filmed with the cutting edge six K camera,
some of the world's top filmmakers,
cinematographers and
scientists came together
to create this incredibly remarkable film,
which marks the first underwater movie,
combining high-end, blue chip
natural history sequences
with the story of a
human/animal relationship
documenting the individual creature
throughout its lifetime in the wild.
The film has of course garnered
a great amount of attention
from conservationists,
scientists all over the world,
as well as celebrities,
and it has received more
than 20 international awards,
including an Oscar, a
BAFTA, the prestigious
Wildscreen Golden Panda, Jackson's
Wildes Grand Teton Award,
the (indistinct), and the
Producers Guild of America Award
for the best documentary motion picture.
For the last six years,
Pippa has been part
of the Sea Change Project, exploring
the underwater forest of Cape Town.
Prior to joining Sea Change, Pippa worked
as an environmental journalist,
specializing in the
field of marine science
and conservation and the
intersection between people
in the natural world.
She has worked with some of the world's
top marine researchers and
underwater photographers
and has been an avid free diver herself
for more than a decade.
So I am delighted.
Before that, I would like to
give a super special thank you
to two people who worked really extra hard
to pull this evening's event together.
Tony Sudal, our AV whiz,
who worked very hard
to secure the proper screening
platform for today's event.
His professional expertise
has made this event possible
and he actually helps
us with all our events,
and he worked long hours and
weekends to procure the film
and to actually do the test run.
Tony, I'm deeply grateful
to you for your commitment.
And I have to call out.
(audience applauds)
Dr. Ty Kamp, without
whom much of what we do
in the Franke program
would not be possible.
Thank you so much, Ty, for
everything that you do.
(audience applauds)
Now we quickly announce
some of upcoming events.
So we have a Poynter
fellow journalist writer
who writes for the New
Yorker magazine, Paul Segel,
who will be visiting this semester.
We have talks by Professor
Meredith Broussard
and Kathy O'Neill, both
of whom are investigating
the ways in which big data and technology
are reinforcing race
and gender inequality.
We are still waiting for
the dates to be announced,
so keep an eye out.
And on December 14th and 15th,
we are organizing our annual
Nature of Inference conference
that will draw a close
to that long-term project
that we've been doing.
Anyway, without further ado,
let me turn over to the screen
so that we can all watch
"My Octopus Teacher".
Thank you so much to
all of you for coming.
(audience applauds)
(silence)
So I was curious how long it actually took
for you guys to edit it down
and bring it to this form.
- Forever.
(laughter)
And I haven't seen this
film in two years now,
and this is the first
time I've ever seen it
in a movie theater.
- What? Are you serious?
Because we've all seen it on Netflix,
on our laptops or computers.
You had it?
- COVID.
- Oh, right, right, okay.
- The film came out during COVID, so yeah,
it was pretty amazing actually,
to see it with an audience.
- Oh, wow.
Oh, we feel really honored.
(laughs)
- This is.
- oh my God dear.
- In terms of how long it took.
So for Craig, it was obviously
a much longer journey.
I mean, by the time I met him,
he'd been diving every day for
six or seven years already.
The octopus had died already.
And what that meant was there
was an awful lot of footage.
So the first three months was
just looking at what we had
so that we could start to figure out
exactly where our story was gonna focus.
And then it was three years of editing.
- So it was.
- I imagine, so that's why I
started off with this question
because it has to have been a
gargantuan job of getting it,
but it's beautifully done.
It looks so gorgeous on a
large screen and very moving.
I don't know, somehow
it felt much more moving
on the large screen.
I had to hold back tears as well.
But I would like to open it up
to questions from the audience.
I have a couple of my
own, but I'll hold back.
So I see an arm go up promptly,
and so we have a roving mic.
So yes, thank you.
- My voice is loud. So I
think you probably hear,
but I will also project through this.
First, congratulations on the film.
Obviously it's been very, very accolade.
It's got many accolades
and very well awarded
and very well deserved.
And I'm sure you've heard that
a million times.
But I wanted to know ,when
he says you were a visitor
and we're not just a visitor,
we're a part of this.
Did you ever feel like there's
Craig or did he even feel
or relate to you that, you know,
I feel like I'm encroaching on their space
and I am changing how the camera may.
I'm an actor, so the
camera con always changes
the way you look, it's just natural.
So it would change the behaviors
of the different wildlife
that you were coming
into interaction with.
Is that something that
you were cognizant of
or is that something that you
got more comfortable with,
if that's at all possible?
Or is it just, was it a daily
struggle maybe, just to.
- I mean, I think these are
things where you're evolving
all the time as an, as an
individual and as a storyteller.
And it was something that
I was very conscious of
the whole time because I'd come
from a very scientific, journalistic place
where engaging with animals like this
was actually completely alien to me.
But when I started diving
with Craig and seeing
how he engaged with animals
and seeing how animals
actually approached him,
many of these creatures,
they don't have to be there.
He's not gonna go and
kind of chase them down.
And I guess my attitude
started to change slightly.
And I still, I think
it's very, very complex.
I think you do change their behavior.
I think in some cases it's negative.
In some cases it's not, because they are
as curious as you are,
and with most creatures
that live underwater, they
can swim and move a lot better
in the ocean than we can.
But what I'm increasingly conscious of
is what kind of message
are you putting out?
Because Craig is incredibly
experienced, respectful,
and kind of loving towards these animals.
But I don't know if you
can always expect everyone
to go into natural spaces like that
and more and more in our work,
because I still work
with Sea Change Project.
I'm not sure today if we
would make a film like this
because we've seen so much more.
But that said, I think that
separating people from nature
is where all the problems
have started anyway.
- Why would you film like
this again, just for the.
- Well, because I think it is complicated.
How close should we be
getting to the natural world?
- So you do feel like the
negatives outweigh the positives?
- No.
= After doing it? No.
- No, not at all.
Yeah, 'cause I didn't feel.
- [Priya] It's real that
the negatives are real
because you are perturbing,
you know, their life cycle,
you're intervening in
a way that, you know,
it's not entirely clear if you're welcome.
- Right.
- Exactly.
- So it's an intervention.
- But you would say the same thing
about putting tags on sharks
or putting tags on baby turtles
or any kind of biological study.
And if we don't do those things,
how are we gonna learn anything?
So I would say the positives
far outweighed the negatives.
- Right, t Then why wouldn't you do
something like this again?
- Because I've done it.
- Oh, in that sense.
I thought you meant in terms of just like
that you felt that there
was more negative messaging,
maybe social media wise
or anything where people.
- I mean, we got a lot of criticism.
- Of course.
- And we expected that, I mean,
my next film is also about a relationship
between a human and an animal,
but that animal's being rehabilitated
so that engagement is inevitable.
So it's a slightly different situation,
but it's just tricky. I mean.
- Of course.
- Well it sounds like the
next project is something
where there's a restoration
for the animal, right?
You're trying to restore it back to its.
- Original place in the wild. Yeah.
- Yep.
- Do you wanna run it? Thanks, man.
- I think is okay, it's for the recording
that we would like to have the mic.
Do you just wanna throw it?
You can actually catch it.
It's a soft box, so.
- Whoa. Oh, that's why
it's called catch box.
That makes, you can throw it now.
I got it now.
Yeah, I didn't get it
for the longest time.
Thank you so much for being here.
And that was wonderful.
It was my first time seeing
it on the big screen,
but not my first time seeing it.
I wanted to actually ask
about free diving, you know,
as opposed to diving in general,
like being a scuba diver
and somebody who works
on reefs in particular.
I find free diving almost
at this really funny
and strange activity.
This is strangely dangerous,
but also like very particular,
like people who do it,
you know, those who I've met don't see it
as a dangerous activity,
which is always something
that's surprised me.
And continues to, so in your
work with Sea Change and also,
you know, you work with
Craig and stuff like that,
how have you sort of come to
think about diving culture
and free diving's place
in it as part of a world
where I think, you know,
we rely on tanks so much,
or snorkels or this or that or like,
you know, the shallow
versus the deep, you know,
how do we think about
diving culture, you know,
with large through free-diving,
which you know, yeah.
- I mean, we dive to engage
with the natural world
and to find things out
and to take photographs.
I've never really, and I
would actually like to,
but I've never got into free
diving as an adrenaline sport,
which it obviously is in a massive way.
anyone's seen "The Deepest Breath"?
It's just an incredible way
to explore things underwater.
And you can go anywhere free diving,
you can hike to a bit of like
completely unexplored kelp forest
that's an hour away of
anywhere you can get your car.
And all you need is a mask and a snorkel
and some fins and a camera.
You would never be able to
get there with scuba gear,
without a boat.
And the other thing that's
been incredible in Cape Town,
which was partly due to COVID
and partly due to the film
and partly just due to a
growing underwater community
is free diving has become
a massive, massive thing in Cape Town.
And diving without wetsuits
has become a massive thing.
And in a country where access to nature
is not democratic at all,
and you've got a massive,
massive gap between poor
people and wealthy people,
being able to engage
with nature in this way
without having to have loads and loads
of expensive equipment
is pretty revolutionary.
Yeah.
- {Priya] Yeah.
So the next question is here she had,
oh, I think it was so first.
Okay, I'll give.
- Very shocking that I
managed to catch that.
Thank you so much.
I've never seen the film before
on the small or large
screen, so it was beautiful.
And I had a question for you.
So you were talking about
the narrative and editing,
and I was hoping you
could speak a little bit
to the role of gender in the film,
because obviously this
is a female octopus.
That's revealed at the
end when she gives birth.
But I noticed the entire time,
Craig sort of refers to her as she,
and I think it's sort of interesting
because you have this imposition of a very
sort of human idea and almost,
I sensed a bit of almost
a kind of like at times,
paternal at times, romantic way
that he's framing this relationship,
which I think really does
add something to the film,
but perhaps at the cost
of imposing, as I said,
a sort of human idea of gender
or of relations onto these animals.
So I'm just curious if you
could talk a little bit more
about the positives and negatives
or anything you wanna
say about the choice.
- He wasn't gonna call the octopus it.
I mean, in no universe
you can see the kind
of respect and reverence
he has for that animal.
He was never gonna say it
did this and it did that.
And she was dead, you
know, two or three years
before we did the interview.
So he'd always known
that she was a female.
So I mean, were we imposing anything?
I think we were just telling a story
where the animal happened to be female.
What does it mean?
I'm not sure.
I think if the octopus had been male
and there hadn't been this
kind of story of motherhood,
we would've ended up with a very,
very kind of masculine film.
So I think that we were
actually really lucky
that the energy of the octopus
was there to balance out
this other very strong
father/son narrative
which went through the film.
And you know, again, that
that wasn't a creative choice.
Craig just happened to
have a boy, not a girl.
- Right. I guess just to be clear,
I didn't mean in the sense of
like a dehumanizing effect,
but more just I think
we're trying to think
in binaristic different ways about gender
and what that means and the relationship
between sex and gender. So
more in that sense, but.
- yeah, thank you.
Very interesting.
- This question and then throw
back where you got it from.
- Yeah. Oh God.
- Thank you.
Hi. Thank you for hosting this event,
and thank you for coming.
And this is my first
time watching the film,
and I was so impressed
by how perfectly crafted
the narrative sequences were.
And like those chase
sequences were almost,
they reminded me of
"The French Connection"
and how well crafted they were
and all these like shot reverse shots
between the octopus and Craig.
I am wondering more like
from a technical perspective,
how much was shot after
the fact and how much
was Greg's original footage? Yeah.
- So pretty much anytime you
see Craig without the octopus,
that was filmed later,
what was quite amazing in
certainly the chase sequences
and many of the hunting sequences,
Craig was on one camera
and Roger Herrock's friend,
who shot most of the
underwater, was on a RAID.
So that's how you have
those reverse angles.
- Right.
- You've got Craig with
his little tiny handycam
like racing around and
Roger on his big raid setup.
- That's super impressive.
- That's fantastic given
that there was no shadow.
I was looking really hard to see, I mean,
who's the filmer, right?
Where's the shadow?
- I saw a shadow once.
- You did?
- Which I'd never noticed before.
I only saw tonight
because of the big screen.
(laughter)
It was a flash.
- I didn't see it.
- Let's see. I definitely didn't catch it.
- So I did a similar thing
this summer with deer,
a family of deer that were
out where I used to run.
Not here, in Connecticut,
but I would go back every day
and I found that in watching
them how they react to me,
I started seeing more
instinctual behavior by humans,
particularly how we look
at or regard strangers
who were coming at us and
the whole predator/prey thing
and that sort of thing.
And so I'm wondering if his
experience with those animals
had resulted in him gaining
insight on human beings
and how instinctual we are.
- Very much so.
- Yeah.
- I think during this
time, and I see Craig
do it with other animals now,
anyone who understands animals well
is doing this all the time.
And you're constantly
moving out of human mind
into animal mind as best you
can because we are humans.
And that's the framework through which
we understand the world.
And there's a lot of criticism
about anthropomorphism,
but the truth is that
every single living thing
on this planet wants to live.
And there's the dichotomy
between life or death.
And that means that we've
gained all of these instincts.
And in the human world, those
instincts have translated
into emotions, but ultimately
it's the same kind of
physiological driving forces
that are making us feel these things.
So I get quite frustrated
when people say things like,
you know, an octopus can't feel emotions
because why we think our emotions,
which are really just survival instincts,
are above what an animal experiences
is really just extremely arrogant.
- And I thought it was just
follow up in terms of him
not wanting to intervene
between, there's a shark.
It's like he's almost like, well,
I'm in the position of God here.
- No, I thought it was very self-conscious
because he said, "I
shouldn't intervene in nature
the order of."
- But if he's part of, this is my point,
if he's part of nature, if he's in there,
if he's not a guest, if he's in it,
then him intervening in that,
he's part of the system.
- He's not part of the natural
order of the system, right.
So this is not his habitat.
- I think he is though, but
he's in there, he's swimming.
That's natural.
- I mean, this was the biggest thing I was
kind of confused about
while making the film
and that was the choice he made,
it's not necessarily the
choice I would've made.
- Correct.
- And I found it confusing.
Okay, well you're not gonna
save it from the shark,
but you think it's okay
to feed it mussels.
Feed her mussels.
And for Craig it makes sense.
And I think that's what we do as humans.
You know, some of us say, well,
I'm not gonna eat octopus
because I saw this amazing movie,
but I'm gonna keep eating
lamb and chicken and cows.
- Right.
- Exactly.
- And we are all making
these personal decisions
that feel right to us,
and they are hypocritical
and they don't make perfect sense.
- Yeah, and they're often
contradictory, right.
I mean, I'm a vegetarian and have not
eaten any animal knowingly, but
I have squashed ants, right.
I mean, I do, I mean.
I'm more gentle with spiders.
I ask them to leave and I
gently, you know, but ants,
I'm always squashing.
- And mosquitoes?
- I've never been lucky in squatting
any of them or swatting
any of them, I think.
Okay. We will close with one final, okay.
Maybe two final questions
because I don't wanna keep you
much longer from the yummy
food that we have upstairs.
- Steven.
- Okay.
- Thank you.
It's a really extraordinary movie.
My second time viewing it,
and seeing it on a big screen
really amplifies so much
of the incredible messaging
that you've created I think, in this film.
One of the things that sticks
with me is consciousness.
Is how this film, and I think things
that really change our
perception of the world
is the way we see it.
And I think one of the things
that I was struck with,
was early in the film,
the way you set it up
with his trip to Africa and
acknowledging that these guys
were seeing things differently
than he could ever see them.
And there was this sense
of like, he wanted that,
he wanted to have that
depth of connection.
Do you feel that in making this film,
and I know you had your
background in the sciences,
did you find your perception,
your consciousness has
changed towards nature
just in the process of making the film?
- Absolutely.
I think just making this film,
I was spending two, three
hours a day underwater
with those animals and even
without an indigenous lens,
which is something that I'm
very, very interested in now
and exploring very deeply,
just spending that much
time surrounded by nature
in that way and kind of putting yourself
at the mercy of it, at
the mercy of big waves,
big sharks, currents, that
completely changes you.
And yeah, it just, in some ways
things become much simpler,
but then in other ways
more complex, I suppose.
- Yeah, I can imagine that
it makes you feel vulnerable
and yet stronger somehow,
because you kind of survive
every time you go and you come
back out successfully, right.
Maybe.
I can only imagine.
There's one final
question before we close.
We just pass the mic.
- Thank you.
Thank you so much for being here.
Thank you so much for the film.
This is probably a bad last question,
but I was wondering like,
could you talk about like
the genesis of the project?
Like how you found the story
or how the story found you, maybe.
- It's quite a long story,
but I'm gonna try and speed it up.
I was working as a conservation journalist
for a marine conservation NGO.
And I was speaking to all
these incredible scientists
all over the world, and I
was hearing their stories
of how they were working
with these animals
and immersing in environments
and having these magical experiences.
And two things happened.
Number one, I became a
little bit frustrated
that they would tell me
these things on a call,
but if ever it was an interview
or I asked them to write
a blog or anything else,
they took all the emotion out
of everything that they wrote.
And I found as someone
who was really trying
to make a difference in the world
and bring the natural
world to life, I was like,
if the people who are closest to nature
are unwilling to talk
about how they really feel
about nature, what chance do we stand?
So that was the first thing.
And the second thing was I started feeling
like I was vicariously
experiencing all these things
and I desperately wanted
to have my own connection
to the natural world.
And Craig was doing
talks all over Cape Town,
not about the octopus,
but just about the kelp forest in general.
And I ended up going diving with him
through a mutual friend.
And yeah, about six months later we'd done
a couple of small projects together
and he asked if I would like
to help him make the film.
And at that point I really thought
I would just be carrying a tripod.
I did not expect it to evolve
the way that it did on any level.
- Fantastic. Thank you
so much for coming and
(audience applauds)